the only reason astrology is not
scientifically respectable is because no
one can hypothesize how the coupling
takes place in other words how can the
transit of mercury be coupled to an
event system on this planet but don't
despair we know that the Sun radically
affects the weather on the earth but no
coupling system has ever been proven for
that either it's just the statistical
correlations are so overwhelming that
that it's impossible to ignore I think
probably the key to understanding
astrology is you're going to have to go
outside of astrology to understand it to
something like fractal resonance the
reason the pattern in the Stars is
repeated in the passing of your life is
because there's only one pattern to
begin with it isn't that the stars cause
you to be the way you are anymore of
them that you cause the Stars
to be the way they are there is not a
causal relationship here what there is
is a series of adumbration
and reflections that are this is you
know a great discovery that has been
made in the past ten years one of the
greatest intellectual steps ever taken
by human beings a new law of nature is
now discernible and I can state it for
you
it's that nature is self-similar
across scale
you understand what that means it
explains why an atom looks like a solar
system and why they both look like a
galaxy because nature is self-similar
across scales it means that you know if
a certain architectural conceit works on
one level Nature will use it on any
other level where it seems appropriate
and and so on many many levels the same
patterns repeat and so it wouldn't
surprise me at all if in the next while
we got the equivalent of astrology but
quantum ology quantum ology where
instead of calculating downward from the
stars to the context of human state you
calculate upwards from the atom to the
context of human faith and if you keep
calculating you can go from quantum
ology to astrology and leave out
sociology and show you know that these
things are reciprocal reflections of
each other then the mystery and the
woowoo of astrology I think would just
simply disappear and be replaced by an
of course how could it be otherwise kind
of understand